[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dansions parler
sport l'émission à ne pas manquer si
vous êtes un passionné de sport local et
plus précisément de sports yves binois
aujourd'hui au programme comme toujours
une dose de bonne humeur des analyses
sportives et surtout des coups de gueule
et des débats nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous en plateau ou via écran interposé
pour s'exprimer sur cette actualité
sportive revinoise présentation il est
avec nous via écran interposé vous
reconnaissez sa musique les passionnés
de cyclisme de roller de voile et du jeu
pokémon go il est toujours de bonne
humeur quand on parle de sport yann
dujarrier le capitaine et avec lui dans
cette émission
pour michael bonjour comment allez vous
et yann super super comment vous
souvenez que je joue toujours à pokemon
co ag les bonnes informations c'est
parce qu'à chaque fois que j'arrive à
l'émission je suis en train de le choper
ce qu'il peut y avoir sur plateau c'est
pour ça c'est ça c'est ça apparemment
vous êtes le meilleur dans votre secteur
non je suis un petit joueur mais je
comme comme comme pour tout j'essaie de
super tôt mieux c'est un sport aussi un
il faut le dire
alors on continue par un monument il est
également avec nous via écran interposé
c'est la personne dont tout le monde
parle c'est un entraîneur de rugby qui
n'a pas sa langue
bosch il apporte toujours de la joie et
de la bonne humeur dans cette émission
attention à ne pas l'énerver coach
fournissent ex-entraîneur de plaisir est
avec nous éveillez vos jours bonjour a
rejoint michael bonjour à tous
et ben moi je suis pokora yann moix
aussi créé j'arrivais sur le plateau
j'essaie de choper tout ce qui bouge
d'accord des pokémon bien sûr oui on l'a
vu sur un vrai quand même vous me
connaissez vous pouvez ces jeux vous
êtes enfin en tout cas appelé leurs
formes
on va voir ça dans cette émission à
l'homme ce rôle
sur le plateau on aura également avec
nous grégory canale l'italian lover de
tv soit 118 il connaît tout sur tout et
c'est un jour important pour lui car
c'est son anniversaire priori comment
allez vous bah ça va très bien je
rejoint le club des trentenaires michael
des trentenaires déjà c'est ça tu j'ai
signé la tout juste dans ce club je suis
la nouvelle recrue du mercato poste près
presti va puisque l'était pas encore
arrivé et quand vous sentez vous du coup
aujourd'hui un anniversaire c'est
forcément un jour spécial
oui c'est un jour spécial je me sens je
me sens très bien j'ai eu un beau cadeau
de la part des clubs anglais de foot on
a vécu tous les deux michael parce qu'on
est deux fans de football de jour assez
difficile à s'effondre sur sur le
football peut être une belle issue et la
fin on va parler tout à l'heure de de la
super league
et donc parler aujourd'hui très heureux
de parler de sport devrait sport celui
qui donne une place très importante au
mérite donc c'est la fin de la super
league le jour de votre anniversaire
grégory est ce que c'est un à un hasard
je ne sais pas peut-être peu la lettre
voilà alors en tout cas on va passer au
programme de l'émission va parler tout
de suite des jo de tokyo maiva
hamadouche sextuple champion du monde de
boxe ea bf pourrait être porte drapeau
de la délégation française cet été au
pays du soleil levant
la boxeuse qui s'entraînent à elancourt
au boxing club de saint quentin en
yvelines a été présélectionné elle sera
en concurrence avec six autres athlètes
de haut niveau pour la première fois il
y aura deux porte drapeaux un homme et
une femme
le duke sera désigné par des
ambassadeurs de chaque fédération
olympique via un système de points pour
les jeux à paralympiques c'est l'athlète
nantenin keita qui a été présélectionné
pour être le porte drapeau de la
délégation française avec 11 sportive
cet ancien pensionnaire de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
déficientes visuelles a notamment
remporté quatre médailles olympiques
dont une en or sont 400 mètres aux jeux
paralympiques de rio
les heureux élus sont connus autour de
la fin du mois de juin
est ce que ces athlètes ces deux
athlètes yvelinoise mérite tout
simplement d'être porte drapeau oui ou
non ou été on oublier la petite raquette
à en oublier la petite allia
d'effectivement j'y vais forcément où
j'ai dit oui parce qu'elle se passer
voire 50 ans ni ville du personnel
ils ont leurs raquettes directement à
distance alors gens mais il mérite de
toute façon là on parle on parle on
parle de demain y va
puisque qu'elle mérite par rapport à son
palmarès mais je pense qu'à ce niveau là
il est où le mérite c'est si ce n'est
qu'à voir un sportif avec un palmarès
hors du commun comme teddy riner à
l'appui a pu l'être et qui est
indétrônable et à ceux à ce point là
mais indiscutable après tous les
sportifs qui se rapporte au drapeau et
apple qui va pas démérité donc giresse
et c'est pour moi pour eux et pour tout
le monde un grand honneur d'être porte
drapeau de la délégation française lors
des jeux olympiques
donc bien sûr qu'elle ne mérite pas à
puce je la connais personnellement et du
coup forcément elle représente bien les
valeurs françaises
mais elle est adorable à tous points de
vue au niveau humain au niveau sportif
c'est une policière il faut le rappeler
cette policière de deux métiers et une
fille qui est qui et qui est exemplaire
dans tous les domaines sportif humain et
qui a des qualités énormes toi fais
aussi beaucoup d'action également pour
contre les violences faites aux femmes
également elle fait beaucoup d'action
l'état et associations de la f1 c'est
bien sûr parce que non mais c'est bien
et c'est moment c'est vraiment
outre la compétitrice parce qu'elle aime
palmarès éloquent que ce soit sur le
plan amateurs que professionnels aux
professionnels elle a 23 combats et une
défaite donc 18 par ko fait c'est un
palmarès éloquent et en plus humainement
comme je le dis je le répète humainement
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui est très
équilibré qui a le coeur sur la main et
qui est vraiment une belle personne
vient du jarrier si vous êtes d'accord
pardon vous êtes d'accord avec jean car
oui je la connais pas du tout donc du
coup après le portrait que j'en viens
viens d'en tirer en effet je ne pense
qu'elles qu'elles le méritent
quel mais amplement maintenant moi j'ai
pour souvenir des déportés drapeau avec
avec beaucoup plus de résonance et de
médiatisation au préalable un teddy
riner un david douillet d'un seul à la
gazelle leur message de l'un des leurs à
faycelles part que dans ce qu'on ait des
maréchaux ferrants mais je pensais à
notre championne du 4 du du 400 m voilà
d'aider des personnes qui avaient eu des
résultats beaucoup plus résonnant de
manière médiatique et c'est vrai que là
7,7 bourse euse moi j'en avais jamais
entendu parler avant
alors après du fait qu'elle ne fasse
telle qu'elle fasse un sport que je ne
suis pas du tout non plus avec la boxe
jeune et j'ai toujours dit c'est quand
même quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
familier est un sport avec l'âge j'ai du
mal à comprendre l'intérêt mais met donc
donc voilà voilà une des raisons pour
être sur les deux matches et c'est vrai
que pour moi une judokate une zotac
comme clarisse bah oui à la rayonnante
et le et le
nos commandes à j'ai pas trouvé le mot
voilà elle tient pour moi c'est elle qui
devrait être porte-drapeau féminin parce
qu'on va faire on va faire la liste 1 la
judoka du coup clarisse agbegnenou je
vais arriver à le dire elle ça faisait
johan des faits sandrine gruda
basketball maiva hamadouche du coup à
box kristina mladenovic tennis mélina
robert michon disque
charline picon en planche à voile samir
ait said gymnastes maxime bono canoë
kayak
renaud lavillénie florent manaudou
natation et astier nicolas équitation
voilà est-ce que ça vous parle
cette femme est tellement cinq hommes là
j'avais trouvé un déséquilibre dans les
présélectionnés je ne comprends pas non
plus pourquoi pourquoi il ya plus de
femmes présélectionnés que que d'hommes
celui là je ne vois pas je ne vois pas
l'intérêt
je pense que présélectionnées des gens
c'est aussi faire des déçus donc je
pense que plus la liste sera pourrait
plus y aura une short list ou moins il y
aura des déçus voilà c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être des des athlètes qui ce
projet dès qu'ils voient déjà lors de la
cérémonie d'ouverture avec le prendre à
fond et puis ensuite parce que c'est pas
juste sur la sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture s'est aussi accompagnée
d'athlètes très présents sur l'événement
pour justement ma de donner de l'envié
et des encouragements aux appelés pour
défendre notre pays donc
donc voilà je trouve que c'est peut-être
se projeter pour certains un certain et
il y aura des déçus et sablage macasty
fans qui se posaient suez llorach il n'y
aura seulement quatre hommes
donc ouais je vois pas trop l'intérêt
d'avoir couvert pour penser de cette
liste la presse avait permet peut-être
de les mettre en lumière également
sévèrement grégory quel honneur
représenter la france est porte drapeau
il ya le disait très bien c'est un rôle
qui va au delà de cette présence sur la
cérémonie d'ouverture c'est une sorte un
peu de capitaine de la délégation
française
et cette année alors il ya cette chance
cette nouveauté avec deux porte drapeaux
un homme une femme au vu de ce qu'a
rappelé jean le parcours de maiva
hamadouche boxeuse avec ses six titres
de championne du monde qui lui ont valu
d'ailleurs le surnom d el veneno le
poison en espagnol mais aussi par son
engagement dans la police on engagement
associatif à la voile à plusieurs
vecteurs plusieurs engagements sportifs
associatifs et aussi dans le travail je
pense qu'elle incarne ces valeurs
olympiques elle et elle incarne ces
valeurs du sport et elle pourrait tout à
fait être le porte drapeau français aux
jo en tout cas l'un des deux porte
drapeaux
si on aura 2 après c'est vrai que ça a
été rappelé michael vous l'avez rappelé
la liste des concurrentes face à maiva
hamadouche est plutôt rude avec avec
l'aris avec nous avec kristina
mladenovic avec mélina robert michon
charline picon ça va être très difficile
de l'emporter ce qui va jouer aussi
c'est les modes d'attribution parce
qu'ils sont différents entre les jeux
olympiques et les jeux paralympiques
pour les jeux olympiques c'est deux
ambassadeurs sur les 36 fédérations
olympiques et qui vont désigner qui vont
attribuer des points aux athlètes donc
peut-être que ce système ce système peut
lui profiter à maiva hamadouche parce
que c'est un moyen terme ça en interne
pas par rapport au grand public précise
exactement ça et c'est peut-être moi
dire davantage de connaisseurs et qui
pourrait donner davantage de chances on
va dire un maiva hamadouche au contraire
des jeux paralympiques où là c'est un
vote qui sera ouvert au public qui aura
lieu courant du mois de juin et la
banane un kite à elle a vraiment le
profil pour être porte drapeau est là
une médaille d'or paralympique une
médaille d'or olympique qu'elle a obtenu
96 c'est ça donc elle a tout à fait le
profil pour l'emporter avec ce vote du
public qui sera ouvert en jean donc
pourquoi pas avoir deux porte drapeaux
qui sont passés par les yvelines en tout
cas on va dire c'est tout le mal que je
leur souhaite
nantes un cake hier un peu plus connus
ans quand même au niveau du grand public
peut être jean oui oui on va dire oui
mais après comme l'a dit
grégory c'est en interne que ça se fait
et c'est beaucoup mieux parce que on
sait malheureusement le dis souvent auto
autotour la fin de cette émission c'est
qu'il y à il ya des sports et davis
phinney qui ne s'offre à vous
représenter alors juste à leur juste
valeur on va dire
mais force force de reconnaître que la
mise à part les grands sports enfin les
sports qui font beaucoup d'audience
après il ya des sports qui
malheureusement ne sont pas assez à
l'antenne
et comme ça se fait en interne je pense
que ces gens là ont largement leur place
pour être reconnus comme des grands
sportifs en interne au sein même du lulu
du cercle sportif et non pas en prenant
en compte le la relation avec le public
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
avons parlé à tennis le tournoi de
roland garros va être décalée d'une
semaine est ce que c'est une bonne idée
nous allons tenter de répondre à cette
question
coup de projecteur également sur la
super league tend à décrier le psg
doit-il rejoindre cette nouvelle
compétition sa compétition qui n'aura
sûrement pas lieu
mais avant de développer ces thèmes en a
parlé à l' de golf
[Musique]
le golfeur évinois lanthane heureuse
noeuds réalisé une très belle
performance au championnat du monde de
match-play à austin au texas fin mars
des matches en un contre un le
pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles s'est brillamment imposé face
à l'un des favoris du tournoi le numéro
cinq mondial brian 2 chambaud l'une des
stars sur le circuit américain
le français de 28 ans a ensuite perdu
contre l'anglais tommy fleetwood avant
de s'imposer dans son troisième match de
poule contre le sud-coréen cire ou kim
résultat insuffisant pour sortir des
poules le 64e mondiale devrait encore
remonter au classement dans les
prochaines semaines la question sur
cette thématique antoine ros nurse et il
fait un nom en ayant battu ce joueur
bright zone de champs beau nom pour vous
oui on fait un petit duel entre vous y
allez et grigori grégory vous commentez
préserver tout simplement et c'est pas
fait un nom face à brighton de chant
beau parce qu'antoine rose n'a on en a
parlé déjà dans cette émission pour moi
à mon sens il s'était fait un nom
même avant il faut pas oublier que pour
sa première saison dans l'élite l'an
passé il avait hérité du titre
en tout cas honorifique de meilleur
joueur issu du challenge tour
l'antichambre européenne donc on en
parlait déjà sur la scène mondiale il a
gagné déjà deux tournois le qatar
masters en mars 2021
le dubai world championship en décembre
11 décembre 2020 donc à mon sens de
battre deux chambres où ça lui donne une
légitimité supplémentaire mais le nom il
se l'était déjà fait dans le dans le
golf mondial ça va l'aider à progresser
peut-être que les adversaires vont
davantage le craindre à l'avenir mais
pour moi il s'était déjà fait un nom est
déjà une place parmi parmi le golf
mondial en tout cas les noms qui vont
compter dans les prochaines années bien
dujarrier qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez grégory suis d'accord avec ce
qui va venir mais met donc oui un peu
par rapport à la question moi je pense
juste grâce à ça on peut dire qu'il a
confirmé qu'il confiance qu'il a pu déjà
démontré au préalable et voilà et là
c'est vrai que ben canton monde une
marche comme ça c'est toujours pas
évident fans voilà les l'adaptation est
pas toujours pas toujours évident pas
toujours simple donc voila voila sur sur
un premier
sur un premier match il est comme ça à
ce niveau-là il confirme qu'il est à son
niveau et il rapporte un point à son
équipe donc
donc bravo maintenant on va continuer de
le suivre
et en effet on va on va lui souhaiter de
continuer à obtenir ces beaux résultats
et peut-être et peut-être ben voilà
maintenant après abbas et c'est de
remporter des titres majeurs et au moins
d'aller chercher des beaux résultats sur
les sur les les tournois dont on parle
le plus gens qui vous a convaincu ce
volet 2 un peu les deux parce que c'est
vrai que je plais de raison c'est qu'un
pur attention faut pas froisser grégory
un seul jour de son anniversaire un
genre je rejoue elle qu'un grégory sur
le fait que c'est pas parce qu'il a bâti
la battue que ça lui donne fait que ça
le que ça le met en lumière entre
guillemets parce qu'effectivement il a
cité ses deux récentes victoires sur
l'european tour là à dubaï et au qatar
kg fait faire un bond un bon je crois
qu'il est sûre ça le troisième mondial
aujourd'hui une quatrième effectivement
et d'un top 60 monde est à 64 et
mondiale exactement ouais 63e au 15 mars
2009 est de 1 pour mille fois où je
regarde un truc
il a peut être reculé d'une place depuis
un nom mais cette troisième et au 15
mars 2021 sur le site de la fédération
française de vol donc je passe je lui
remettre en question la fédération
française de golf donc d'autres voies
sur cette prod quatrième c'est quand
même actuellement c'est quand même le
joueur français jour de golf en france
et qui est inquiet quelques albums
groupe
il est il est numéro 2 numéro 2 français
derrière victor perez et ça chacun que
ce joueur était
en 2009 ils étaient numéro 6 c'est donc
il a une intention quelque est assez
assez importante sur ces deux dernières
années et ces années 2000
puisqu'on est mort juste et 2021 et que
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être parce
qu'il est quoi qu'il a moins de 30 ans
quand même 28 ans voilà 28 ans il est
passé professionnel en 2016 aulas donc
donc pourquoi pas aussi avoir et les
sciences un pic principal en 2019 donc
c'est quand même très très récent quand
même si on arrivait un sur le circuit
mais voilà donc pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas recherche
on cherche des entre guillemets ddd des
sportifs des porte drapeaux pour pour
faire reconnaître puis développer le
golf en france
il a fait partie ce jour là en fait
partie
il a il ya de belles performances
actuelles il a le vent en poupe et ça
peut nous faire fait ça peut faire que
du bien au golf au phrasé est ce que ça
ne va pas lui mettre peut-être trop de
pression peut-être yens dujarrier à ce
qu'on connaît police l'histoire de
victor dubuisson par exemple le quai t1
à la ryder cup pour le surnommer à
cactus boy parce qu'il avait réussi un
coup incroyable dans l'arizona
et finalement il n'a pas supporté toute
cette pression qui avait autour de lui
d'être numéro un français il a été même
un moment 17e mondial il n'a pas
supporté finalement la pression est ce
qu antoine ros ne peut la supporter en
sachant qu'il est peut-être jeu l'usagé
quand même que victor dubuisson au
moment de son explosion
je le connais pas encore une fois je le
connais pas personnellement donc ça
c'est des choses que celle autour âge
qui peut aider justement à supporter ces
pressions et en effet c'est quand même
un mal un peu un peu française d'avoir
du mal à
ça a peut-être du mal à perdre et aime
pas gagner et donc du coup à se rentrer
dans une spirale un peu négative donc là
pour le moment c'est pas du tout son cas
il est vraiment dans le dans la bonne
dynamique il a des résultats qu'il
confirme et c'est pas juste du coup
d'éclat voilà c'est celle de la
continuité c'est de la confirmation donc
donc pour l'instant
et puis qui lui met la pression
l'avantagé du golfe c'est quand même
c'est un sport qui kahn qui restent
mineurs dans ce qu'on peut dans ce qu'on
peut en entendre régulièrement dans les
médias donc
donc pour moi en france mais aux états
unis dans le monde entier il ya
énormément de spectateurs et dans ces
cas mais qui est ce qui vous met la
pression aux sportifs dans ces cas
restent c'est l'entourage et donc à
l'entourage de justement gérer ça et
pour faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
donner le meilleur demi à chaque
compétition c'est tout n'a pas explosé
en vol c'est antoine et dans ce cas je
ne l'espère pas mais s'il veut côtoyer
les grands et s'installer durablement
peut-être dans des classements plus au
mondial la 64e 63e c'est déjà très bien
il va falloir qu'ils voient là il va
falloir gérer cette pression là savoir
la gérer
et moi je pense au contraire que d'avoir
battu un top 5 mondial s'est même le
numéro cinq mondial de chambaud ça va
lui apporter de la confiance
une certitude qu'il peut rivaliser
peut-être pas tout de suite mais avec
les plus grands à l'avenir après il perd
contre tommy fleetwood mais voilà il
peut s'installer durablement moi je
pense dans l'élite et ça va lui donner
de la confiance
après on espère bien sûr qui va aller au
delà de cette pression et qui que ça va
lui donner pleine confiance pour la
suite et de chambois à peu près sont
l'âge et c'est lui les têtes d'affiché
on peut le dire aux états unis il arriva
à lancer la balle à plus de 320 mètres
un des fois donc c'est une excellente
performance est une excellente
performance à ce que vous le voyez c'est
ma dernière question sur cette
thématique est ce que vous le voyez
peut-être à la ryder cup peut être pas
cette année qui sera aux états unis mais
peut-être dans deux ans à rome
jean peut-être oui oui oui on parle d'un
ton d'ordinaire
oui tout à fait oui pourquoi oui
pourquoi pas si continue son ascension
tel qu'il a un taux pilat pourquoi pas
parce que encore une fois mais voilà il
sait lalanne était il est numéro 2
français derrière victor perez et et il
a actuellement toute légitimité
pourquoi pas être pris sur la ryder cup
on verra s'il ya du jarrier et je veux
dire c'est non mais juste
il reste deux ans pour pourquoi tu es de
progresser et démontrer qu'il sera
indispensable sur la prochaine ryder cup
en europe voilà on sachant qu'il n'y a
eu que trois français dans l'histoire
qui ont participé à cette ryder cup et
je le rappelle c'est un petit peu la
coupe du monde du golf
et il ya eu thomas levet et jean van de
velde et victor dubuisson justement qui
a participé à cette compétition 2014
et c'est à partir de cette date là
vraiment qu'il a commencé à descendre
justement après cette exposition
médiatique
un mal français
moi je vais dans le sens de mes
camarades il a deux ans pour travailler
là cette année effectivement ça va être
trop juste pour intégrer cette team
europe mais dans deux ans pourquoi pas
s'il continue à confirmer sur sur la
scène mondiale il a deux titres à son
actif il est 64e mondial 63e peut-être
je pas froisser gens mais en tout cas il
a il a les clés il a toutes les clés en
main maintenant on va voir les prochains
mois les prochaines années vont être
décisives mais il a en tout cas le temps
devant lui pour travailler être à cette
ryder cup à rome en 2023 alors on va
maintenant passer à votre envol et
justement grégory le moment fort de
cette émission ne zappez surtout pas
c'est le moment à ne pas manquer c'est
sa mission toutes les deux semaines il a
travail et il a un retravaille les payer
juste pour singe le signal je le voulais
absolument pas la pression grégory de
quoi allez vous nous parlez d'une
annonce qui a eu l'effet d'une bombe
dans le monde du football dimanche 18
avril au soir
la nouvelle est révélée 12
grands clubs font scission de l'uefa la
fédération européenne et de son trophée
phare la ligue des champions pour créer
de leur côté leur propre compétition la
super league parmi les frondeurs six
clubs anglais trois espagnols 3 italiens
la super league a pour objectif de
réunir chaque saison 20 participants
pour ce tournoi 15 équipes permanentes
et cinq invités c'est une ligue quasi
fermé donc avec une promesse se partager
une juteuse enveloppe de droits télé la
banque américaine jpmorgan promettait
d'ailleurs d'apporter un financement de
3,5 milliards d'euros pour cette
création
oui mais voilà c'était sans compter sans
l'opposition quasi unanime du monde du
football qui s'alarmait de la mort
probable de ce sport et des pressions
politiques et populaires de la part des
supporters du monde entier menace de la
fifa de l'uefa d'exclusion des équipes
et des compétitions nationales
interdiction aux joueurs concernés est
de porter le maillot de leur sélection
les tensions étaient telles que
finalement seulement 48 heures après la
naissance de la super league les six
clubs anglais quittent le navire et le
projet vole en éclats aussitôt alors au
milieu de ce marasme une équipe
française à regarder les choses à
distance mais non sans intérêt oui le
paris saint germain qui malgré sa
puissance financière n'a pas fait partie
de cette liste des douze fondateur de la
super league le club a pourtant été
approché selon des dernières
indiscrétions comme le bayern munich
également mais a refusé de rejoindre les
sécessionnistes au rang duquel le club
de la capitale souhaite pourtant se
hisser et ça peut se comprendre
à un an de la coupe du monde au qatar
nasser al khelaïfi pouvait difficilement
se mettre à dos les instances mondiales
le président du paris saint germain est
aussi d'ailleurs à la tête du groupe b
in média diffuseur de la ligue des
champions dans plusieurs pays il avait
donc des intérêts ne pas rejoindre dans
un premier temps cette super league même
si cette position aurait pu être
difficile à tenir
au final mais malgré tout il se pourrait
que le psg sortent grandis de cette
séquence il n'y a qu'à voir les
différentes réactions suite à cette
décision et emmanuel macron tout d'abord
qui a salué cette décision parisienne la
position adoptée par le club parisien
est aussi alexandre c'est ferrin le
président de l'uefa qui a remercié
chaleureusement al khelaifi nasser merci
du fond du coeur tu montres que tu es un
grand homme et que tu respectes le
football voici ses mots
longtemps critiqué pour son statut de
club et a de nouveau riche du football
psg apparaît aujourd'hui comme l'un des
seuls à ne pas avoir cédé à cette
tentation
et comme défenseur du football populaire
ç'aurait pu faire sourire un lieu encore
quelques jours mais plus forcément
maintenant c'est bien l'image qui en
ressort écouter d'ailleurs à ce que
disait le président el rey life i à ce
propos le paris saint germain a la ferme
conviction que le football est un sport
pour tous et j'ai été constant sur ce
point depuis le tout début il faut
rappeler qu'en tant que club de football
nous sommes une famille et une
communauté dont le coeur est constitué
de nos supporters et nous devons nous en
souvenir nous devons nous en souvenir
est d'ailleurs nasser el khelaifi a
assuré par la même occasion à sa place
dans les hautes instances de l'uefa il a
été réélu pour un mandat de trois ans au
sein du comité exécutif de la fédération
européenne comme représentant de
l'association européenne des clubs le
psg semble finalement être le grand
vainqueur dans cette crise de la super
league est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec grégory le psg est il de grands
gagnants de cette histoire finalement
oui ou non jean peut-être oui oui oui
j'ai dit oui j'ai dit oui j'ai dit oui
parce que ben ils n'ont pas adhéré ils
n'ont pas adhéré à ce projet là ils ont
eu peut-être la réflexion la réflexion
intelligente de dire ça n'aboutira pas
parce que c'est trop gros
c'est c'est malvenu c'est
là on est on est sur des stratégies
c'est là déjà le football génère
beaucoup d'argent mais là là là là on se
demande où était la place du sport dans
cette danse est super league
là c'est plus c'est plus du sport c'est
csla négoce s'est cdu place vince et ses
voiles à cesser gérer des entreprises à
haut niveau
alors le psg à dinan aussi parce que
justement c'est peut-être pas une
entreprise c'est de l'argent du qatar
c'est pas le même on va dire c'est
peut-être pas le même
donc ils ont peut-être pas besoin non
plus n'ont pas les mêmes besoins
peut-être que cette réflexion a été fait
a été fait par rapport à leur situation
par rapport à l'or à leur potentiel donc
mais en attendant je pense qu'ils
sortiront grandis de cette décision il y
à du jarrier vous êtes d'accord avec
jean si j'ai bien compris je suis
complètement d'accord et j'avoue que bon
alors là c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pourrais comprendre cette volonté de
créer une nouvelle ligue c'est que ça
la future version de la champion's
league va faire augmenter le nombre de
matches pour gagner là bas niveau quand
j'aurai maintenant
maintenant je vois je suis entièrement
d'accord faut que le foot reste un sport
populaire et déjà aujourd'hui ils
coûtent déjà beaucoup trop cher ou aux
spectateurs pour pouvoir le regarder je
sais pas ce que ça aurait pu donner sur
sur 7 sur cette ligue mais c'est vrai
que sur cette super league
mais mais bon voilà pour moi je pense
que c'est un bien que quelques qu'elle
est que comment que l'oeuf et étaient
tout de suite
réglez voilà avec ça n'allait pas ça
n'ait pas été beaucoup plus long que les
négociations ont été très rapidement
menés et je pense que la réponse des
instances à faire en sorte que de ce
fait les les états il y aura plus de à
nouveau deux tentatives de faire ce
genre de ce genre de compétition annexe
je précise qu'il ya dujarrier vous êtes
chez vous aimez vous avez un petit bébé
avec vous mais vous tentez quand même
malgré tout de faire cette émission
c'est s'est jamais simple je pense que
c'est le quotidien un peu de toutes les
personnes qui sont en visioconférence
tous les jours en france en ce moment
pensent ce confinement mais vous êtes là
un chien de le signaler
job en effet je suis je suis désolé mais
blanche ou s'amusant voilà c'est mon
petit scooter ça fait partie du
quotidien en ce moment du coup pour vous
à grégory qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant
du coup pas de super league c'est ça
alors pas de super idée a priori ça ça a
été annoncé le projet n'ira pas plus
loin même si pourrait être remodelé
c'est ce qui a été annoncé
moi je pense qu'il a fait chavirer le
navire on en a parlé je les dis c'est le
départ ces six clubs anglais c'est les
six clubs anglais je pense qu'ils ont
attiré notamment la gombe jp mangane à
investir c'est 3,5 milliards d'euros qui
était promis qui a été avancé sur la
table on sait que le championnat de
première ligue c'est plus regardé au
monde c'est là où sont générés
le plus gros montants les plus gros
montants de droits télé et à partir du
moment où ces locomotives anglais sont
partis c'était très difficile de
maintenir la position pour les autres
clubs les les trois espagnols et trois
italiens même si dans les trois
espagnols ya quand même le real madrid
le fc barcelone dans les clubs italiens
on a quand même la semil en ligne ter et
la juventus donc à elle seule ça fait ça
fait je vais calculer très rapidement
mais ça fait 11 ligue des champions 12
ligue des champions même à toutes les
trois sans parler de celle du real
madrid
donc il était difficile de tenir cette
position après moi je pense c'est ce que
j'ai dit dans dans la chronique le psg
sort grandi de cette séquence et
profitent peut-être d'une super league
qui a tout de suite été on va dire
détruite par le départ de ces clubs
anglais j'ai du mal à croire après une
coupe du monde peut-être au qatar qui
seraient déroulés en 2022 que le psg
aurait pu maintenir longtemps cette
position ne vais pas adhéré à ce gotha
européen puisque disons le c'est l'élite
du football européen qui cherchait un
peu à fermer la ligue à ne pas forcément
l'ouvrir aux autres clubs et ça supprime
et moi c'est ce qui c'est pour ça je
disais tout à l'heure j'ai été abasourdi
en début d'émission
c'est ce qui enlève un peu le mérite
sportif et qui même s'il n'est qu'il
existe - aujourd'hui dans le football
parce que le football est dominé par
l'argent et ça fait des années que c'est
comme ça eh bien il restait une petite
part de mérite sportif et on voyait de
temps en temps dans la ligue des
champions de petits clubs rivaliser avec
les gros budgets et je pense que la
super league aurait supprimé tout ça du
coup c'est stratégique selon vous le psg
a joué stratégique finalement selon vous
à jouer à jouer stratégique dans un
premier temps en attendant de voir ce
qui se passe ils ont joué la carte de la
patience de la prudence est finalement
passé une carte à mon sens ce qui va
s'avérer gagnant pour nasser al-khelaifi
rapidement autour de la table si je peux
dire qui va gagner cette demi-finale
entre le psg et city ça sera la semaine
prochaine le 28 avril
pour vous qui va remporter cette double
confrontation qui va se qualifie pour la
finale
j'en ai peut-être ont commencé
j'avais dit j'avais dit le psg l'année
dernière avait bénéficié quand même de
tirage au sort qui recule en faciliter
l'accès à la finale
là par contre de cette année on peut pas
dire on ne peut pas dire ils ont battu
que mayer le bayern alors allez y aura
les mac et les joueurs on s'en fout on
s'en fout ils ont battu le bayern et qui
était favori un des favoris de la
compétition
moi maintenant avais tu vas le fabricant
tombale favoris mais on devient le
favori de la compétition
donc pour moi mais je vois le psg alou
yann pour nous mais pas mieux c'est vrai
que c'était tout ce que j'avais pensé en
effet ils ont battu le favori et tout le
monde craignait le bayern sur les quarts
de finale maintenant le psg fait mais ne
fait plus office d' outsider mais
vraiment deux femmes deux grands favoris
et j'espère réputation on doit être
derrière eux vont du français c'est
c'est le club le club de la capitale
s'est pourtant pas le club que je
soutiens à dents dans le championnat
mais je suis désolé on a on a envie de
devenir à nouveau champion d'europe est
de gagner la coupe aux grandes oreilles
de la ramener en france tout simplement
voilà donc à fond derrière le psg et
puis après ballon d'or pour les ballons
d'or pour voir qu'il a démarré ou pour
neymar a peut-être on ne sait pas qui va
payer les français débat français thomas
bravo
grégory alors vous on sait que vous êtes
un spécialiste des pronostics je suis je
suis très bon pronostic vital est
preneuse attention à l'eau très bien ce
que grégory va vous dire mon indignation
du psg en quarts de finale dont je
voyais le bayern passé au vu de
l'histoire au vu des précédentes
rencontres
c'est vrai que le psg sur les deux
matches a profité peut-être d'un nombre
d'absents assez considéra du côté du
bayern munich mais pas que attention le
psg a fait un bon match retour sur le
match aller s'est fait dominer mais au
final ils vont quand même mérité sur les
deux matchs cette qualification donc là
dans ce duel on va dire des nouveau
riche du football entre manchester city
et le paris saint-germain
je verrai comme le paris saint-germain
l'emporter et se qualifier pour pour la
finale dont la cote de city vient
d'augmenter jusqu'au mans vient de me
dire l'instant l'otan qui attention les
parisiens semblent avoir la baraka
puisqu'a priori kevin de bruyne devrait
absent du côté manchester city belge
joueurs majeurs cette équipe le joueur
majeur de cette équipe de city donc
peut-être que le paris saint germain va
pouvoir profiter de ces absences en tout
cas à toutes les cartes en main pour se
qualifier pour cette finale
maintenant parler à tennis on passe à
notre page débats le tournoi de roland
garros a été officiellement reporté
d'une semaine par la fédération
française le rendez vous se tiendra donc
du 30 mai au 13 juin avec des
qualifications du 24 au 28 mai ce report
devrait concerner 3 illinois la
française chloé paquet originaire de
versailles le saint germanois arthur et
9 900 29e joueur mondial était également
le jeune antoine ghibaudo 16 ans pour le
tournoi de roland garros juniors la
question sur ce thème
est-ce que c'était une bonne idée de
décaler d'une semaine oui ou non voter
oui oui genre oui pas de débat il ya que
vous avez été le premier à dégainer
comme d'habitude c'est à vous sprinter
un jour spector toujours non alors en
effet sa pause au problème pour le reste
du calendrier pour faire un tour de main
avec ce qui pouvait avoir lieu après
après roland garros a peut être un peu
compliqué ce décalage d'une semaine
maintenant voilà on vit depuis
depuis une année depuis un an des
conditions assez exceptionnelles et ça
fait un an qu'on vit dans dans
l'adaptabilité perpétuelle donc pour moi
il faut que tout le monde puisse adapter
et décalée d'une semaine peu peut-être
permettre d'abord tenir et d'avoir un
accueil supplémentaire
donc oui c'est une bonne idée c'était
une carte à jouer on n'est même pas sûr
que cela permettra que cela permettra d
amélioration des changements mais voilà
s'il y avait un coup à faire
ben il fallait le tenter je pense que
oui séné c'est une bonne idée genre oui
je rejoigne own je rejoignais c'est une
bonne idée et ils n'ont pas pu faire
plus d'une semaine parce que sinon il le
il aurait déplacé de
sur une échelle plus longue mais
seulement ils avaient raison parce que à
wimbledon du coup le deuxième tournoi le
troisième tournoi majeur de cette saison
de tennis c'est trois semaines plus tard
du coup trois semaines plus tard ça sera
du 28 juin au 11 juillet donc forcément
il pouvait pas décaler de trois semaines
un mois rend là donc c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça ils ont fait le maximum
le maximum ils ont décalé ce tournoi au
maximum pour essayer de d'avoir à la
baraka et de se dire que ça ça ira mieux
c'est à cette période-là et pour pouvoir
faire un tournoi on va dire dédé est le
plus près du meilleur quand on va dire
parce que personne ne sait exactement de
quoi sera fait demain donc c'est
compliqué mais là ils ont ils ont reculé
au maximum il pouvait pas faire mieux et
c'est normal grégory oui ils ont fait au
mieux au maximum d'autant que ce qui a
été dit voilà ça a été dit par yann et
par jean juste après c'est la saison sur
herbe qui commence il ya le tournoi de
wimbledon qui arrive fin juin début
juillet qui n'a pas bougé ces dates
donc il y avait une fenêtre de tir on va
dire très réduite pour pour décaler ce
tournoi de roland garros pour le
maintenir bas dans cette fenêtre un peu
historique sur la fin mai début juin qui
est un peu bas voilà on sait que fin mai
début juin c'est à porte d'auteuil que
se passent les choses à paris à cette
période l'année dernière pour vous de
sortir votre manager pas l'occasion d'y
aller souvent j'y suis allé deux fois
dans ma vie mais c'était déjà très bien
mais en tout cas oui ne pas revivre ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a vécu la saison
dernière avec un tournoi qui a été
décalé fin septembre début octobre
alors certes avec des matchs qui ont pu
jouer sur un court central qui peut se
fermer en night session etc
mais un tournoi somme toute assez triste
avec moins de 2000 spectateurs avec un
temps pas au rendez vous donc essayons
gipa que fin mai début juin le temps
sera forcément rendez-vous peut-être pas
mais en tout cas laissons cette fenêtre
historique de roland garros pouvoir se
dérouler et laissons un maximum de
chances pour qu'il y ait le maximum de
public
on parle notamment du retour du public
dans les stades
une semaine après après la fin de roland
garros à peu près dans les mêmes
périodes il ya le début par exemple de
l'euro de football où on parle carrément
d'avoir 25% de jauge de spectateurs dans
les stades donc on pourrait imaginer
aussi plus de spectateurs à roland
garros donc il fallait se laisser je
pense le maximum de chance pour pouvoir
accueillir le maximum de personnes et
c'est une histoire d'argent également
roland garros ça représente en général
je parle pas l'année dernière mais en
général 260 millions d'euros sur 325
millions de budget de la fédération
française donc on est obligé l'organiser
un forcément genre vous avez tout dit
vous étudiez michael on peut pas se
passer de ce tournoi c'est pas possible
donc après malheureusement on le sait on
est tous on est tous conscients de la
situation sanitaire actuelle
cc c'est difficile pour tout le monde et
le choix était fait en concertation avec
tous les comités régionaux au niveau de
la fédération de golf de tennis pardon
et
et on ne pouvait qu'adhérer à ce choix
donc ils vont là dijon recul au maximum
et on leur souhaite
on leur souhaite une réussite pour conso
tournoi qui était né tournoi majeur et
nous sommes partis du grand chelem du
tennis mondial
dernière question sur cette thématique
on va parler peut-être de la préparation
arthur et loch ness le saint germanois
que qu'on a pu avoir au téléphone
récemment nous disait que son programme
d'entraînement était millimétré pour
arriver en pleine forme le jour de
roland garros pour les qualifications
forcément une semaine de décalage ça
perturbe tout est ce que ça va vraiment
le perturber est-ce que ça a perturbé
tous les joueurs ou pas du tout des gens
je vous vois soit rien non mais non meir
et combien il est comme il est classé
combien sans 29e joueur mondial
bon c'est bon je veux pas dénigrer je
veux pas lui jeter la pierre mais quand
même il a dit que ça les ballons tout le
perturber énormément mais ça pouvait
jouer un petit peu dans sa préparation
les nadal et djokovic le disent
également que ça peut jouer oui aux
ailes ça peut jouer ça fait jouer faux
faux faux arrêté général est tellement
minime et très sportivement sortir un
entraînement millimétré jeu il faudrait
qu'ils m'expliquent exactement où ces
millimétré sur sa préparation parce que
honnêtement je connais aussi un petit
peu quand même le sport de haut niveau
donc que je serais curieux de savoir à
quel à quel endroit précis soit sans
préparation et millimitré et que une
semaine de décalage peut engendrer le
conséquence de résultats
là je souhaitais que ça peut jouer sur
le sport de haut niveau quand on fait du
sport de haut niveau
oui mais justement il met justement oui
je parle de sport de haut niveau et
j'aimerais connaître les détails précis
sur sa préparation millimétrée qui vit
qui qui ferait jouer
une différence sur ses résultats par
rapport à sa préparation à une semaine
près j'ai du mal à croire à ce genre de
choses je je je
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes d'accord
avec chambre comme j'ai besoin qu'il est
d'accord avec vous également bah oui on
connaît beaucoup d'où l'on connaît
beaucoup de sport ou en effet il ya des
compétitions qui dure sur une seule
journée
et en effet il faut être prêt mais là on
est calme juste d'une semaine allez ça
veut dire que l'on fait un travail
supplémentaire pendant une semaine
la période de juin avec simplement
décalée d'une semaine
et puis bah ça voilà maintenant faut pas
oublier quand on vient sur roland garros
on vient pas pour faire un match qu'on
vient pour jouer pendant quinze jours
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut être en
forme pendant quinze jours il faut pas
être en forme au premier tour il faut
être en forme pour la finale moi si je
pars sur 1 sur 1 sur un tournoi je me
dis il faut que je sois en forme
et ouais sur sur plusieurs jours nous
quand on va enfin voir un championnat du
monde où ça joue sur trois devrait lui
il faudra il faudra sûrement les
qualifications donc il faut qu'il soit
prêt le plus tôt possible
donc ils sont trois semaines dont trois
semaines bon il fait son temps par
roland garros mais en tout cas ses
premiers matchs de super important pour
lui
on est d'accord mais si on veut laver
lourdes ne peut pas arriver justement
être au taquet pour son premier match et
du coup prendre le risque de perdre le
troisième match et de même pas rentrer
sur tableau final donc le match pour me
plus important c'est le tableau final
c'est pas les ne laissez pas les trois
matches de qualification d'accord je
connais pas assez en tout cas de
l'intérieur le sport de haut niveau pour
me prononcer je vais faire confiance à
ayamé est gentil mais sur le sol chinois
s'est fait tôt le sport amateur
après dans l'interview que vous avez pu
vous avez pu réaliser avec qu'arthur
englert neige c'est vrai qu'il disait
bon voilà c'est ça peut ça peu un petit
peu joué notamment peut-être sur des
participations de tournoi avant qui
serait peut-être compromise parce que le
calendrier est légèrement modifiée
peut-être que ça peut le perturber je ne
sais pas si ce sera déterminant
je ne le crois pas et je suis plutôt de
l'avis de jean et diane sur sur le sujet
et je ne pense pas que ça perturbe aussi
des grands comme nadal je pense pas que
cela l'empêchera d'aller peut-être
empoché son 14e titre à roland garros
alors on va parler mal
il a géré son excuse si jamais il ya des
gens viennent ici mais voilà déjà une
excuse s'ils perdent c'est bien ça alors
on va reparler golf c'est un nouveau
coup dur pour l'open de france de golf
déjà nul et en 2020 le rendez-vous 2021
est officiellement reportée il ne se
disputera pas à huis clos
du 6 au 9 mai sur les greens saint
quentinois la décision fait suite aux
nouvelles annonces gouvernementales
concernant la propagation de kobe 19 en
france on écoute philippe pilate aux
envies des âges est cadré on a beaucoup
travaillé de façon très proche avec
european tour avec la préfecture avec
les différents services et la décision
qui a été prise
au total cette 104e édition et attire
entre 850 et 900 personnes venus de 25
pays différents
une difficulté dans le contexte
sanitaire actuelle pour les
organisateurs c'est compliqué oui
effectivement c'est compliqué
actuellement des notions et 850
personnes pour lui faire manger d'accord
donc faire manger lui 150 personnes en
respectant les contraintes sanitaires de
deux mètres carrés par personne
problème qu'il faut résoudre le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
attend désormais une nouvelle date dans
le calendrier du tour européen le rendez
vous pourrait être décalée à la fin de
l'été l'événement pourrait cette fois-ci
accueillir un peu de public la question
sur cette thématique est ce que c'est la
goutte d'eau la goutte de trop pour ce
rendez vous qui a tant souffert ces
dernières années
oui ou non oui oui pour vous grégory en
fait un petit duel entre jean et y
analyse yann vous commencé mais oui pas
de problème je commence non je dirais
que il est plus à ça près le tour de
quoi aujourd'hui
mais peter détails voilà il n'y pas un
décalage pourrait il pas une perte de
sponsors
après tout ce qui a pu arriver voilà en
effet il va y avoir du travail pour
pouvoir redorer le blason pour pouvoir
regagner regagner des organes y ait des
échelons dans la hiérarchie des ddd ddd
des tournois pardon mais mais voilà je
pense que c'est pas c'est pas grave ce
n'est qu'un élément parmi tant d'autres
j'avais du mal à comprendre parce que
pour moi le golf c'est un sport
justement qui aujourd'hui peut se
pratiquer dans des conditions sanitaires
très dans de très bonnes conditions mais
en effet faire venir des gens de 25 pays
différents
c'est là où en effet ça peut ça peut
apporter compréhension à la
problématique qui pouvait avoir
je pense que c'est une bonne c'est une
bonne raison il ya un il y avait il y
avait quelque chose qui était compliqué
la date était quand même assez proche je
dirais que si ç'avait été six avaient eu
lieu au mois de juin
je pense comme problème aurait pu être
abordé de manière différente mais là
c'était la meilleure solution et voilà
maintenant je pense pas que ce soit
quelque chose qui fera qui fera mourir
l'open de france il est déjà phoenix et
et il va renaître de ses cendres dans
l'enfance et pour préciser un vos propos
ce qui posait surtout problème c'était
également la restauration le midi pour
toutes les équipes et également
l'hébergement parce que forcément il
fallait que tout le monde soit hébergé
plus ou moins au même endroit et c'est
ça qui peut poser problème
j'aurais même personne c'est bien pour
les golfeurs genre c'est à vous oui mais
justement et justement il ya des liens
deviennent disait que ce ce tournoi
n'est pas zappé mais si justement 6e a
parlé déjà plusieurs fois les cette
émission et que retrouver cette date qui
pour moi était la meilleure par rapport
à beaucoup de choses par rapport au
timing sur les tournois par rapport
rapport à la période autant puisque
c'est un sport d'extérieur et donc il
avait retrouvé cette date qui lui
convenait bien
eh bien là malheureusement bien sûr
c'est une année fait c'est une année ces
deux années particulièrement à ce que
leur lait on parle plus d'années
particulière au singulier qu'on commence
à parler à plusieurs années c'est une
année particulière par rapport à a oco
vide mais malheureusement
malheureusement baisse est ce
déplacement de date va encore affecter
le prestigieux du tournoi forcément
alors après on sait pas encore la date
cette fin d'été mais on le sait on en a
parlé on a déjà débattu de ce sujet sur
le plateau si ça se fait un bel été mais
en ile de france amf et n'était ça veut
dire que si on a la possibilité d'avoir
un peu de public
si léon nouveau les portes un petit peu
au public mais en plein été en ile de
france il y aura très peu le public on
le sait ça c'est des débats qu'on a déjà
eu donc non c'est sûr que ça fait pas du
bien malheureusement à ce tournoi qui
est quand même le grand tournoi de golf
en france et on ne sait pas s'il aura
lieu en surtout on pense qu'il sera
reportée mais pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune date 1 à l'heure actuelle je sais
où on botte dagory ce qui vous a
convaincu moi dangereux pour moi ce qui
est le plus dangereux c'est que la date
nouvelle nouvelle date ne soit pas
encore trouvé c'est ça qui est parce que
ça peut être bon on reporte et puis et
puis aba on vous reporterez en 2022
ça peut ça peut finir comme ça et ça ça
pourrait être dangereux et s'est
fortement envisageable un d'après la
fédération française même si pour
l'instant il espère quand même ils sont
petits mise sur sur ce dossier mais
c'est une grosse possibilité
grégory qui vous a convaincu moi je suis
du même avis que jean pour moi c'est la
goutte d'eau de trop on parlait sur ce
plateau de la perte du statut de rolex
séries suite au départ du sponsor
chinois du tournoi de cet open de france
chênaie à chennai g après j'ai un peu la
pression qu'il a gagné un autre statut
solide
tournoi de golf peut-être le plus
poissard du moment un temps m'a maudit
un tournoi maudit peut-être ce cet open
de france et je vais m'expliquer le
tableau avant la ryder cup on avait des
tommy fleetwood d alexander noren qui a
été lui qui avait gagné sur les greens
50 chinois il ya eu celle de ryder cup
les joueurs de ryder cup
bien sûr la ryder cup qui a amené
énormément de visibilité à ce golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis et puis on a un peu la gueule de
bois depuis avec la perte de ce sponsor
perdre ce statut de rolex séries d'un
tournoi qui se déroulait en juin qui a
été déplacée en octobre la dernière
vision qu'on a de se tourner en 2019
avec la victoire du belge nicolas
colsaerts avec un temps qui était pas au
rendez vous salle était à fin octobre
voilà fin octobre c'était une météo
automnale de cette époque c'était
automne alors qu'un an avant on avait
une superbe météo et pourtant sur des
dates qui étaient presque pareil pour la
ryder cup donc le on va dire le constat
est la différence et été faite entre les
deux tournois
on déplace le tournoi on en avait
notamment parlé alors c'était une bonne
chose qui déplace le tournoi et qu'il
installe dans une nouvelle période
peut-être la période de mai et essayer
d'installer ce tournoi dans la durée et
que cette période de mai soit maintenu
et donc c'est pour ça que je suis de
l'avis de jean peut-être la goutte d'eau
de trop une fois de plus c'est décalé
alors que le tournoi a quand même
beaucoup souffert sur ces dernières
années deux parlent la perte de statut
avec la crise sanitaire à l'image du
sport entier mais je pense qu'il n'avait
pas besoin de ça le tournoi et et oui
alors il ya une crise sanitaire oui on
doit s'adapter oui c'était difficile de
pouvoir l'organiser mais je reste
persuadé qu' il ya un petit peu de
malchance dans l'histoire pour l'open de
france et surtout que l'open de france
je tiens à préciser n'avait pas de date
encore récemment ils seront programmées
ces dates là au mois de mai impôts
dernier moment alors que le calendrier
avait déjà été publiée donc ce n'est
vraiment pas certain qu'il trouve une
autre date d'ici à la fin de l'année
est-ce que ça serait aussi mauvaise
image pour les golfeurs de haut niveau
également
est ce qu'il pourrait se dire finalement
j'ai pas envie de faire ce tournoi là
parce que toutes les années il est un
peu maudit il n'y a pas grand chose y a
pas un grand plateau il n'y a pas une
grosse dotation à ce que effectivement
ces jours là peuvent se poser des
questions suite à
ce nouveau report yann charrier alors je
connais pas les règles de sélection et
les règles d'engagement sur sur les sur
les tournois est ce que les gars peuvent
se retourner facilement au rang en
passant d'un tournoi à l'autre est ce
que les engagements doivent se faire
très longtemps en avance
là j'ai pas j'avoue j'ai pas trop le
ferai je connais pas du tout le domaine
mais maintenant une chose est sûre un
jour parce que f
est ce que l'argent va se poser la
question nationale dans les mains
comment les golfeurs aiment venir jouer
sur le golf national
tout le monde dit que c'est un super
eagles qui prennent beaucoup de plaisir
à y jouer donc il manque juste une chose
en fait c'est juste un prize money
suffisant pour pouvoir amener les
grosses affiches parce que le plaisir
ils nous ont quand ils viennent jouer
donc peu importe que le tournoi n'est
pas dupe en trois quatre cinq ans le but
c'est qu'ils approchent de la fin
connaisseur des super league en quelque
sorte du golfe
non mais voilà que les sons les golfeurs
c'est vrai que à partir du moment où il
ya l'argent et on en avait parlé dans le
sport l'argent fait tout donc à partir
du moment où vous aurez suffisamment
d'argent je vous ferai venir qui vous
qui vous voudrez c'est là c'est la seule
chose qui compte donc et après surtout
que en contrepartie vous avez un très
bel environnement
vous pouvez faire loger les gens à
versailles dans des très beaux hôtels
vous pouvez à les accueillir dans des
conditions de très bonnes conditions
et puis et puis après la qualité de jeu
est là quand on quand on vous sur sur
saint quentin
donc pour moi ouais ça ça juhasz a joué
à pas grand chose il faut de l'argent
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez
hoceinia il ya des français qui cartonne
en ce moment on peut le dire à victor
perez antoine ros heures également
il devait être là sur 7 sur cet open de
france finalement on décale on décale
peut-être cet engouement aussi autour
d'eux des golfeurs français en ce moment
oui mais bon là on le dit tous c'est une
guerre une période particulière en
levant le suivi tous dans toutes les
disciplines
je ne pense pas je ne pense pas que les
sportifs français vous avez cité rose
n'est jerez
les meilleurs français collodion
actuellement ont conscience de tout ça
c'est quand même c'est qu'à l'open de
phrases c'est quand même le tournoi
majeur français
ils se doivent d'être présents je je je
je ne vois pas comment alors ici aussi
les étrangers ne viennent pas par
rapport à la dotation qui
malheureusement a baissé énormément
suite au retrait de rolex à entre
parenthèses mais après quand même au
niveau français on sait pertinemment que
c'est quand même le tournoi majeur
on l'a dit redit yann la rose dit c'est
quand même un milieu où les gens aiment
venir par rapport à la qualité du golfe
rapport à l'environnement par rapport à
tout ce qui peut y avoir extra sportifs
et même sportif c'est quand même une
belle compétition nationale est la plus
belle au niveau au niveau sport golf
alors ça sera le mot de la fin sur cette
émission on tenait quand même grégory 1
c'est votre anniversaire on tenait à
vous offrir un petit gâteau
d'anniversaire alors au regard des
enjeux crois que vous êtes fan ans et
harry potter
ces cadeaux de la maison de l'école
poudlard
voilà exactement 30 ans donc on voulait
vous souhaiter un très joyeux
anniversaire
ça me touche ça voilà ton mandat claudie
en régie également 30 ans c'est un cap
qu'est ce que vous allez faire ce soir
du coup je sais pas ce qu'on n'en crée
par comme surprise dans les conditions
sanitaires mais je le disais tout à
l'heure très heureux de rejoindre le
club des trentenaires
il a fallu beaucoup beaucoup de
négociations puisque j'étais bien avec
avec les personnes de 20 ans il plaisait
bien dans la catégorie des personnes de
20 ans mais très heureux de débuter
cette nouvelle aventure avec les
trentenaires mais ben genre va bientôt
nous rejoindre il a causé 15 25 ans et
127 27 ha ha ha je m'étais je m'étais
trompé ya neuf ans et ça aussi c'est
l'année prochaine pour vous moi que jour
d'hui le meilleur club si les
quarantenaires en tout cas encore très
belle année c'est un très bon
anniversaire grégory c'est déjà la fin
de cette émission va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation de l'ancien
footballeur le king eric cantona
je ne joue pas contre une équipe en
particulier je joue pour me battre
contre l'idée de perdre je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]
oui